sehr geehrte der präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
noch nie hat es eine bundesregierung
gewagt in so wenigen sätzen so viele
angriffe auf die grund und
freiheitsrechte der bürger auf
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratische
prinzipien unterzubringen wie in diesem
gesetzesentwurf die vorgeschlagene
ergänzung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
ist ein alarmierendes dokument
obrigkeitsstaatlichen denkens dieser
rückfall in den autoritären ungeist geht
vom kanzleramt aus und von ihnen frau
bundeskanzlerin ihr misstrauen gegenüber
den bürgern und den demokratischen und
rechtsstaatlichen institutionen hat bei
diesem gesetzesvorhaben eindeutig die
hand geführt
sie misstrauen den bürgern deswegen
wollen sie sie tagsüber gängeln und
nachts einsperren
sie misstrauen in ländern und kommunen
deswegen legen sie die axt an die
wurzeln der föderalen architektur der
bundesrepublik und machten
ministerpräsidenten landräte und
bürgermeister per bundesgesetz sie
misstrauen den gerichten den berufenen
kontrolleuren staatlichen handelns
deswegen stellen sie die amts und
verwaltungsgerichte durch
zentralisierung kalt möglicherweise weil
diese nämlich eben zuletzt einige ihrer
eingriffe in die bürgerrechte gekippt
haben und nun lassen sie sich eine
ermächtigung ihre wortwahl nicht meine
ins gesetz schreiben rechtsverordnung
mit zustimmung des bundesrats zu
erlassen
wir sagen dazu ausgangssperren sind
unverhältnismäßig und verfassungswidrig
für millionen von menschen die nicht so
privilegiert boden wie zum beispiel
mitglieder des bundeskabinetts sind sie
die hölle im kampf gegen das virus in
ausgangssperren dagegen nutzlos ja sogar
kontraproduktiv
die infektionsgefahr ist nun mal im
freien fast null und hängt auch nicht
von uhrzeiten ab willkürlich
festgesetzte incident zahlen als
ausschlaggebendes kriterium sind
ebenfalls absurd sie hängen von der zahl
der durchgeführten tests ab und lassen
sich nach belieben hochtreiben ohne
rückkopplung an die tests quote den
anteil tatsächlich erkranken und die
alterskohorten der betroffenen sind sie
auch nicht aussagekräftig das bestätigen
viele wissenschaftler zuletzt der
frühere chefideologe der charité
professor krüger hört auf die
wissenschaft so lautet ihr mantra sie
aber hören nur auf die stimmen die sie
hören wollen und die ihre vorurteile
bestätigen
widerspruch tun sie dagegen als
verschwörungstheorie ab dagegen wäre
doch eine differenzierte und
transparente debatte dringend nötig um
bessere entscheidungen treffen zu können
ging es ihnen tatsächlich in erster
linie um die pandemie bekämpfung hätten
sie längst geeignete und zielgerichtete
maßnahmen ergreifen können die auch wir
hier immer wieder eingefordert haben
kobi 19 ist vor allem für bestimmte
risikogruppen gefährlich dann muss man
auch diesen bedrohten personen gezielte
schutz angebote machen statt die
grundrechte für alle einzuschränken und
das ganze land an die wand zu fahren
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
verhindert man weder mit zusperren der
gesellschaft noch mit
krankenhausschließungen und abbau von
intensivbetten sondern durch gezielte
investitionen in personal und
infrastruktur
dafür hatten sie genug zeit die nicht
genutzt wurde
sie wollen wir diesen gesetzen etwas
anderes den endlosen bundes lockdown
obwohl fünf monate wellenbrecher
lockdown mehr als genug gezeigt haben
dass dieses primitive rezept überhaupt
nicht funktioniert und sie nehmen in
kauf dass der mittelstand zugrunde geht
der arbeitsmarkt staatliche dauer
intervention zerstört wird
dass innenstädte veröden eine ganze
schülergenerationen verloren geht und
das kultur und vereinsleben stirbt sie
belegen ganze branche mit berufsverboten
sie hält eigenen händler und
gewerbetreibende gastronomen und
tourismusbetriebe durch monatelange
zwangsschließung ohne aussicht auf einen
ausweg zahllose geschäfte werden nie
mehr öffnen
generation alte familienbetriebe
verschwinden für immer in
unternehmerischen mittelstand bricht das
rückgrat
auf deutschland kommt eine
insolvenzwelle von nie da gewesenen
dimension zu ein massiver anstieg von
depression geschädigten kinderseelen in
isolation verkümmern den älteren
menschen verstörten jugendlichen und
zerrütteten familien das sind die
kollateralschäden ihrer dauer lockdown
politik
die bürger verlieren das vertrauen in
einen staat der einem vor dem buch vor
dem ruin stehende westfälischen
gastronomen ehepaar das aus verzweiflung
sein café wieder öffnet das ordnungsamt
und hohe bußgelder auf den hals schickt
die bürger verlieren das vertrauen in
einen staat der mit polizeikommandos
rentner geburtstages stürmt und kinder
vom bolzplatz jagd aber drogenhändler im
park gewähren lässt die bürger verlieren
das vertrauen in einem staat dessen
polizisten erholungssuchende in parks
mit zollstöcken schikanieren aber bei
klaren groß hochzeiten untätig daneben
stehen müssen
seit mehr als einem jahr bis brauchen
sie die korona krise um zumutungen
durchzusetzen mit denen sie unter
normalen bedingungen niemals durchkämmen
reise kontakt und versammlungsverbote
das einreißen der letzten haltelinien
bei der staatsverschuldung eine eu
schulden union die das budgetrecht des
parlaments aushebeln und die deutschen
steuerzahler in geiselhaft für brüsseler
ausgaben orgien nimmt und jetzt
versuchen sie am grundgesetz vorbei
unter dem vorwand des infektionsschutz
es eine notstandsgesetzgebung durch die
hintertüre einzuführen
die von unserer verfassung aus guten
gründen nicht vorgesehen ist nichts
anderes bedeutet es wenn sie bürger
pauschal als potenzielle
gesundheitsgefährdung unter
generalverdacht stellen ihrer
grundrechte berauben und einsperren
worden es wäre grotesk und falsch einer
regierung die so oft und offenkundig
versagt und das recht gebrochen hat
derart weitreichende zusätzliche
kompetenzen zu geben
die fdp fraktion lehnt deshalb aus
tiefer freiheitlicher und demokratischer
überzeugung diesen gesetzesentwurf
ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]